fed up with blocking streets apparently
and occupying college campus buildings
black lives matter activists in
California have a new tactic one of the
officers involved in a shooting death of
Stephan Clarke in Sacramento California
was recently married but on his wedding
day he had to confront invading
activists alrighty
Robert Pattillo is a civil rights
attorney he joins us now Robert thanks
for coming on thanks for having me Tami
now look for most of us you've seen that
video we understand it the social
argument about the need for a lot of
people talk about prison reform but
there needs to be justice reform we know
that there are problems culturally that
we have to deal with this though
transcends a line in that we wonder what
is it really going to accomplish what is
your point of view on this because this
just seems not only is it not really
going to accomplish anything on the
issues that we're facing but it really
is a provocative dynamic that changes
this into such a personal framework that
people are going to turn away from what
the real answers could be what do you
say to that well you know Langston
Hughes once asked the question what
happens to a dream deferred and this is
what happens when legislation is not
created they will address Dedes to
people for over a decade people have
been arguing and fighting and marching
for the idea of comprehensive criminal
justice reform in America one of those
hands up don't shoot conservatives had
an issue with it when it was taking a
knee conservatives had an issue with it
when it was I can't breathe
conservatives had an issue of it what
exactly is the protest that these
individuals want people to have that
will get them motivated on the issue of
criminal justice reform we need to have
an actual congressional leadership you
know the White House Ivanka Trump and
the president have both talked about
that the need for prison reform or
justice reform that's a discussion many
black leaders and pastors have visited
the president in the White House and
they get attacked for talking with the
president about policy and about moving
forward with the
shoes would you have a problem would you
go and meet with the president you have
a problem with with black activists and
people at least within the black
community who are leadership meeting
with the president to deal with these
issues directly instead of invading a
private citizens wedding don't you think
one would be more productive than the
other and absolutely I agree view
completely like I have applauded and
said on Twitter earlier applaud to
pastors for meeting with present from
president all day any day on this issue
Frederick Douglass met with Andrew James
Andrew Johnson and 1866 a former
slaveholders to work out issues the only
way you make progress is my meeting
talking and pushing through legislation
the meeting with the pastors and the
President to push the first step act it
was absolutely necessary we need senator
Grassley to stop stop delaying the bill
get it out of your committee your a
civil rights attorney this is a
conversation this is about getting
things done but Americans see on
television this kind of action of people
trying to ruin as they mentioned they
know it's like let's ruin the skies
happiest day in his life you realize
that you're not winning people this is
not a way to win friends and influence
people that that this conversation about
things Americans generally agree on
we're all affected by a justice system
that's unfair but you know isn't this
the kind of thing that just keeps people
distracted away from real solutions you
have to admit that well Tami
unfortunately these are the things in
America get that get attention there's
been more attention on this story than
there was with the 17 pastors meet with
president from last week to post prison
reform about that that's one of the
issues work and when it's with the
communities that the Democrats normally
lay claim to it doesn't get coverage
they don't want to talk about the
president having success instead and
this is what you should be upset about
the media promoting things that make
activist communities look bad and then
they play into it I mean isn't that
something you should be speaking out
against look if you look at the 1960s if
you look at the press clippings from
them they demonize the Freedom Riders
they demonize dr. King as an outside
agitator going into communities there's
never
or acceptable way there's never an
acceptable way to protest until
something is done
I think congressional and presidential
leadership on this issue will be what
stopped duster in American history as
dr. Martin Luther King jr. and we know
the coverage of that and it was powerful
and it made the difference
so when media wants to cover something
properly they will in this case I think
we're all being taken for a ride but I
love your position regarding the
president and really having an influence
on policy Robert it's terrific seeing
you thanks for joining us tonight thank
you thank you so much for everything